[Music]
there's no cash bail thing is nonsense
it's ridiculous it's not working if we
could let the criminals out in those
neighborhoods of those people who claim
that no cash bail is racist they would
understand because their homes would be
broken into their businesses would be
broken into ultimately they talked about
defunding the police and so it
demoralized our law enforcement and so
many of them have left the profession
that's Virginia lieutenant governor
Winsome Sears speaking with Maria last
summer on the impact bail reform has had
on law enforcement's ability to fight
crime across this country last night a
19 year old man with a machete wounded
two New York City police officers just
blocks from the New Year's Eve
celebration in Times Square the FBI NYPD
and Joint terrorism task force are
investigating police sources tell Fox
that the suspect was on the fed's
counter-terror radar for weeks meanwhile
in Mobile Alabama one person is dead at
least nine others hurt in a shooting at
the city's New Year's Eve event major
cities across the country have seen
crime rise and analysts say it's because
of factors including police officers
quitting over a lack of support and soft
on crime prosecutors but Florida has
taken a different approach to combating
Crime recruiting Law Enforcement
Officers Across the Nation to come and
work and live in the Sunshine State
Florida's be a hero program offers
incentives including a one-time bonus of
up to five thousand dollars so far the
state is awarded that bonus to over 600
police officers joining us now with more
is Florida's attorney general Ashley
Moody A.G Moody happy New Year and thank
you so much for joining us tell us a
little bit about what you're doing in
Florida because so many people have
moved there during the pandemic and
after as well crime has been a number
one issue in many of these cities across
the country what are you doing to make
Florida safe safe and why are people
flocking there
well Happy New Year and yes you've seen
the recent news that shows more people
are moving into Florida from other
states than and anywhere in the country
we're we're glad to see that our
recruitment of police officers those
individuals that have signed up for
these incredibly dangerous and Noble
profession are moving here and you know
compare that to New York where they had
4 000 cops walk off the job and I think
that was a huge increase from even the
year prior and we're seeing them move to
the Sunshine State I've attended
swearing in ceremonies where they say
we're just glad to be in a state where
leadership has our backs they openly
vocally proudly support law enforcement
not only that we're helping them buy
homes we're helping them live in the
communities they serve giving them
bonuses giving our First Responders
raises compare that to other parts of
this country where you are seeing while
there's a drastic violent crime increase
take Chicago for example last year they
had a 40 increase in violent crime and
how does that Governor respond totally
revamping their pre-trial release and
bail program
saying that he's doing it for Equity
reasons right mind you these folks Biden
and and Progressive radical Democrats
have hijacked that term it doesn't mean
equality or equal treatment under the
law when they say Equity people should
start looking at at their communities
and thinking about getting out when they
say that they mean we are going to
implement woke Wackadoo weak policies
that will wreck the prosperity and
safety of your community and and that's
the thing right when it comes to crime
and it comes to the criminal justice
system Democrats will say the only way
to cure the injustices in the system are
to use tools like no cash bail cashless
bail but having said that there's got to
be a better way to Institute reform and
it seems like that's what you're working
on in Florida to try to empower the
police raise them up train them better
you know of course there are mistakes
that happen in in any system and we can
work on those things but taking the
money away doesn't necessarily help fix
the problem it certainly leaves the rest
of the citizens at risk
Florida is not immune to the forces that
the rest of the nation is facing you
know but what you have to remember as
leaders in an executive branch that you
have to confront those issues head on
you can't be like President Biden who
wants to ignore there's a criminal
crisis at our border I mean maybe if we
put an ice cream truck at the border he
might actually visit that would be a
great start but you have to confront
these things head on Governor DeSantis
does a great job in fact when we were
seeing an overwhelming onslaught of
retail theft we came in we passed laws
making it easier to prosecute this
organized crime Rings committing retail
theft we instituted new technology to
help us get a better handle on that so
in Florida you know the motto here is if
there is an issue we tackle it head on
we're not going to run away from
challenges and I think if the rest of
the nation did that in a in an
intellectually honest way we can improve
our bail system we can make sure people
aren't sitting in jail just because they
can't afford bail but you can't do what
Illinois is doing and saying you know
totally tying the judge's hands on who
can be considered a Flight Risk saying
it's not violation if you're on house
arrest and you leave for 48 hours just
enough time to commit another drug crime
or another crime I mean it's insane
policies so if you do these things in an
intellectually honest way and you and
you're forceful and meeting these
challenges head on you can make progress
your citizens will feel safe and law
enforcement heck they'll want to be and
live in your state and A.G Moody you've
brought crime down in Florida to a 50 or
low I just want to reiterate that we are
going to have more with Florida attorney
general Ashley moody in just a moment
you're watching Sunday morning Futures
right here on Fox News
and be sure to catch mornings with Maria
with Maria Bartiromo weekdays from 6 to
9 A.M eastern time over on Fox Business
[Music]
and we're back with Florida attorney
general Ashley Moody AJ Moody welcome
back and thank you um I want to talk a
little bit about the border with you
while we have you here Governor Abbott
of Texas governor DeSantis of Florida
they've been criticized for how they've
been dealing with some of the Border
issues when many say they actually
should be commended your thoughts on the
fact that these Governors are left with
no help from the federal government to
fend for themselves
well since day one of this
Administration they have been blowing up
the security measures at our border they
ended the migrant protection protocol
they started again with Catch and
Release I'm going to just point out to
you in the last month of the Trump
Administration we released 17 people
into the interior of the United States
compare that to today it is out of
control they have released hundreds of
thousands of unvetted unprocessed people
into the United States and as our
litigation has uncovered they've lost
track of these people we know that
they're intercepting people on the
terrorist watch list we know that
they're intercepting people who are
involved in drug trafficking human
trafficking drug smuggling it is
unconscionable the breakdown of any
border security purposefully by this
Administration we go to trial next week
on catch and release on their on their
complete disregard in contradiction of
federal law yeah it they have to follow
the law and this is what the Democrats
do and this is related to your last
segment
they come in as exec elected executive
officials from the president on down to
these radical Mayors and they'll say
we aren't going to follow the law
because we don't believe in the law for
political reasons we don't agree with it
and therefore we're not going to follow
it whether it's the Border or whether
it's in our big cities in our other
states and that is when you see a
breakdown in chaos and crime and
meaningful well-intentioned intentioned
law-abiding citizens suffer even in the
communities they profess to protect also
law enforcement in Florida there was
that video of the officer who just came
near a fentanyl during a routine traffic
situation and she passed out
um luckily she's alive but having said
that the Democrats want to put Narcan
everywhere to help people like this and
they should certainly do that but why
isn't anyone focused on stopping the
fentanyl coming across real quick
and this is why Governor DeSantis and
Governor Abbott are trying to get people
to pay attention to the burden that his
place is placing on the resources in our
state you can't go around with policies
like Florida State safely take turns you
got it I'm so sorry we are out of time
happy New Year and thank you for joining
us happy New Year